Iran has a right to exist. Also, they
won't they won't they would strike,
which I have been reliably informed
makes them the most moral army in the
world. Lastly, the children harmed were
used as human shields. Did I miss
anything?
>> They are doing baby they are killing our
people in the dark. Iran is the enemy of
civilization and the enemy and the
danger to the entire world. You got in
the last 48 hours. In the last 48 hours,
they fired a water weapon on civilians
on children. There's a a children's
nursery here. There's an old man old age
person's a home here. Civilians,
families, they fired their weapons on
civilians. And often they use cluster
bombs, which are forbidden by
international law.
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's what
Allah says,
"The gather at the sort of a macabre."
You are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, Masjid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another Masjid
around the area of Norway subhanallah
where there's so many Muslims that do
not have somewhere to pray. This Masjid
is only $500,000. And any donation that
you give will go towards your akhirah
because when you enter that grave,
nobody's going to remember you except
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. So, make it
count, brothers and sisters, and donate
towards this Masjid inshallah. A new
project that's only $500,000. And
believe me, if every single one of us
give 1 pound, 10 pounds, 100 pounds,
1,000 pounds, that's going to be
something you will never regret on yawm
al-qiyamah. And everything that you lose
is going to perish and go. But your
deeds on yawm al-qiyamah are not.
Donate to the link inshallah. Let's get
to the video. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh, brothers and
sisters, dear friends. Subhanallah.
Wallahi al-azim. Allahu Akbar. Allahu
Akbar. Allahu Akbar. Look how Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala works in miraculous
ways.
And before I start the video, I want to
be very clear. I do not condone the
killing of any human being.
And I've made this very clear many
times. Israelis and IDF and these
Zionist cults are not our teachers. They
are not the teachers. They are not
representative of real Jewish people
that we know that I know that I have
friends. These people are violent
individuals. So, I want to make that
clear that while now
Tel Aviv and
different locations in Israel where
their nuclear power plants or nuclear
facilities are headed where where where
they're
operating has been hit, we do not
condemn [clears throat] and we do not
condone
the killing of innocent people. Let's
make that clear. And we also need to
define what is innocent as well because
a lot of Israelis out there, both men
and women soldiers, IDF soldiers walk
with machine guns with them. Okay, we're
not talking about soldiers. We're
talking about innocent people. I don't
care if an IDF
a soldier that's pro-Zionist, full-blown
Zionist that wants massacred genocide on
Gaza people, they're not my teachers.
I'm not going to come and celebrate this
and be like, "Hold on a second. If a
soldier has been attacked all day every
day." I'm so sorry, under the UN law,
yes, UN regulation charter, they have a
right to defend themselves. Iran does.
Every state has a right to defend
itself. However, the matter here is not
that. We're going to be reacting now
from sisters to Candace Owens and many
other people reacting to
Israel being hit and it looks like Gaza.
It look It's starting to look like Gaza.
Again, we condemn the killing of any
innocent men, women, or children for
that matter. However, let's get straight
into it on X. Okay, let's first start
off with this video. I don't know if
it's real or fake, but let's start with
this video. They are doing baby. They
are killing our people in the dark.
16,500
murdered. Shesh that has a Okay, I don't
know if that is real. But let's go to
Candace Owens. Candace Owens says,
"Iran has a right to exist. Also, they
warned they warned they would strike
which I have been reliably informed
makes them the most moral army in the
world. Lastly, the children harmed were
used as human shields. Did I miss
anything?" Now, what is she trying to
say here? She's trying to basically say,
"This is the same word and same
speech sentences used by the IDF.
They're the most moral army in the world
because they let you know before they
bomb you. And when they bomb innocent
children, kids is they use human
shields." She's using the same thing
on Iran and saying, "Look, Iran launched
it. Look, let let you know that they're
going to strike." Yes, and kids were
harmed. She's saying that basically
using the
argument, brothers and sisters,
subhanallah. But you can see clearly
that subhanallah that at the end of the
day, innocent being harmed is wrong. But
they're using the same thing. Like, if
you look at now, Israel Foreign Ministry
said, "The Iranian regime devastated
Arad and Dimona by deliberately striking
civilians with missiles. Over 100 people
injured, including children. A blatant
war crime. Pure terrorism." The issue
here is not what they're saying is true.
The issue here is the double standards.
The thing that we're trying to point out
here is the double standards that's
happening. That is the issue.
Come with me. I want to show you
something.
Look at this.
This is
the face of evil.
This is the Iranian regime ballistic
terror. This
can now happen
in Rome,
in Vienna,
in Berlin,
in Paris.
The only question is whether or not the
Iranian regime will push the button.
And we know the Iranian regime, and we
know that they already pushed it.
Okay. Come with me. I want to show you
So, you can see on that page, as you can
see,
this man is saying this is the face of
evil. If that's the face of evil, do you
have mother of all evil?
This is again, you guys, and it just
bamboozles me. Let's go to Netanyahu.
Forget all of this. Let's go to
Netanyahu. This gets It gets more
crazier when we go to Netanyahu, guys. I
just want to show you guys.
one minute
an explanation of why Iran is the enemy
of civilization and the enemy and the
danger to the entire world. You got in
the last 48 hours. In the last 48 hours,
they fired a weapon on civilians, on
children. There's a a children's nursery
here. There's an old man, old persons
home here. Civilians, families, they
fire terror weapons on civilians and
often they use cluster bombs, which are
forbidden by international law. The
second thing that they did is that they
fired on Jerusalem right next to the
holy places. They sent ballistic
missiles that could have destroyed the
Church of the Holy Sepulchre, the
Al-Aqsa mosque, and the Western Wall.
The three holy sites to the three
monotheistic religions, they don't care.
They fire on everyone. The third thing
they did is they fired an
intercontinental ballistic missile 4,000
km right into Diego Garcia, the American
British base. They can reach now with
these ballistic missiles everywhere in
almost everywhere in Europe. I've been
warning that for years. The fourth thing
that they did is that they shut down the
important maritime strait of Hormuz
trying to blackmail the world with oil
terror blackmail. Four things that
they're doing in 48 hours. And I ask the
leaders of the world, the leaders of the
free world, the leaders of the moderate
states, what more are you waiting for?
President Trump has correctly said that
Israel, the United States and Israel in
this great partnership, we're fighting
the battle not only for ourselves, but
for all of you. And he asked a simple
question, where are you? And it's time
to heed President Trump's call, his
leadership, and his vision, not merely
for our sake, but for your sake. Okay,
this is this is this is you
I'm just trying to understand. If I go
and you've provoked Iran, killed their
leadership over and over and over again,
now that they're attacking you back, you
are deeming it everything that you've
done in Gaza is far worse, far worse.
Again, we're consistent morally, not
strategically. We condemn Iran for if
they're attacking and if there's
innocent people being targeted on
purpose, 100%. I I have to be
consistent, otherwise I am as worse as
you Zionists. I'm not going to come here
and be like, "I'm happy." You know
there's some posts out there who are
like, "Oh, good. Taste your medicine."
No. As Muslims, we need to know better.
We're not going to come and say innocent
Zionist children, women, and kids are
being I condemn it because I have to be
morally consistent. They're not my
teachers. I can't let my vengeance and
anger what they've done to Gaza make me
be like, "Good. Their children." No, cuz
Allah says in the Quran in in Surah
Baqarah, yes, attack the way they've
attacked you, but do not transgress
limits. And the limits is what? Innocent
people. I'm so sorry, I don't give a
Iran, I don't give a Muslim nation, we
will not celebrate the killing of
innocent Zionist Zionist children who
and other children dead. No. Yes, no,
we're not going to do that. And look at
this picture now, which you can see
Iran is uh committing uh targeting
civilian homes. That's a war crime.
Ta-da!
Again, again here, they're trying to
say, "Look, this is what you've done to
Gaza." We're not seeing what Iran is
doing, right? You've been doing that.
That's the key here. Look. Subhanallah.
Look, these are look Again, if you look
at it, "F off, you genocidal war
criminals." People They're not buying
it. I can't even watch that other one.
Subhanallah. Okay. And let's see now how
other people reacted to the attack.
So, you've got another one here. It
says, "Shocking footage from this
evening of a ballistic missile striking
the city of Dimona in southern Israel,
home to 40,000 residents, directed at a
civilian neighborhood, is a war crime.
I'm furious that the world leaders still
refuse to stand up and call out Iran."
I'm genuinely trying to understand the
psychology of these morons.
I don't understand. It's as if they are
saying that they are Like what they say
they say they believe they are the
chosen people. Okay. So, that means that
they basically, in a nutshell, say these
guys, "We can do that because you guys
we deem you to be Amalek. You guys are
evil. Therefore, we can attack your
homes, etc., because we believe you're
inherently evil.
Because we are good, you can't do the
same back." That's exactly what's being
told. "We have the up the the moral high
ground, and we are the chosen ones of
God. We can wipe out your children and
kids.
If you do it to us, that's evil." Cuz I
cannot rationalize It's like narcissism.
This is deep, deep, deep narcissism with
flipping Forget gaslighting. It's like
missile lighting, okay? Forget
gaslighting. It's It's It's a
flipping missile lighting. It's
unbelievable. The audacity these people
have to commit a massacre and genocide
in Gaza, and when the same has happened
to them, which we condemn, unless it's
hitting targets in it, "Idea of
soldiers?
Oh, I don't give a damn. Liquefied all
day everyday. However, when it's them,
it's all hell breaks loose. Look at
this.
Nuclear facilities are now attacked. The
the Natanz facility in Iran. And the
video is set to show missiles hitting
Dimona, which house key nuclear
facilities. Okay. So, we've got this
here. Times of Iran news. It says Israel
panicked after Iran attacked in Dimona
and Arad. Meanwhile, Iran FM even after
top Iranian leaderships getting killed.
I don't fear death. Let them kill me. It
will be an honor for me to die for my
country. Courageous whatever whatever
whatever. So, look look in in a
nutshell, guys. Okay.
This here, brothers and sisters, shows
you the deep narcissism the Zionists
have. And you can see by the attacks
that's happening and the reaction of
people like Candace Owens and many other
people calling this nonsense out is that
we have to be morally consistent. At
least one thing you can give to Candace
Owens, Tucker Carlson,
Dan Bilzerian, and many is that you have
to be morally consistent, my friend. You
cannot go and kill innocent men, women,
and children. And that's why Islam
people Islam gives us the moral high
ground. The objective morality, which is
what? That we do not attack innocent
people.
No ifs, ands, or buts. We do not attack
innocent people because they've got
nothing to do with that. These people
are saying we can do it to you cuz they
believe they're the chosen people. They
believe they can get away with it. And
this shows you the deep narcissism that
they have. And that's why Zionists they
are in control of Hollywood, Disney, you
name it, my friend. They want to control
the water you drink. That's how evil
they are. You know why? Because they
believe they're going to control one way
or another. And I've done a video about
this talking about what? They are
reverse engineering for the Messiah, the
Antichrist to come. Their Messiah, which
is an Antichrist. And they do it in
which way? They believe that they we are
the They have to control over us.
And they are already doing that by the
powers. And that's And this is not
anti-Semitism. This is Zionism we're
talking about. They believe that they
are now controlling and they control
everything. The Zionists, let me make it
clear, Zionists control everything. And
And their way of saying they are
dominant over us. And that's the reason
why they are calling this thing the Pido
Island, the FC Pido Island that Liam
Tough, not so tough, the only thing
tough about him is his name, the coward,
Tommy Robinson, do not call those real
pedos out who are raping American little
girls.
For what? To blackmail your elite, so
they can carry on raping those little
girls. And then they can use it against
them if they don't do what they want
them to do. You sickos.
Till next time. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh. Everything
you own, from your clothes to your car,
to your wife or your husband, is going
to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's what
Allah says,
"Hatta zurtumul maqabir." You are busy
with the worldly affairs until you visit
the graves. Brothers and sisters, Masjid
Norway, the one that we built, is
looking to another masjid around the
area of Norway, subhanallah, where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masjid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your akhirah because
when you enter that grave, nobody's
going to remember you except Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. So, make it count,
brothers and sisters, and donate towards
this masjid, inshallah. A new project
that's only $500,000. And believe me, if
every single one of us give £1, £10,
£100, £1,000, that's going to be
something you will never regret on Yawm
al-Qiyamah. And everything that you lose
is going to perish and go. But your
deeds on Yawm al-Qiyamah are not.
Donate to the link, inshallah. Let's get
to the video.